hey guys ran right here and I'm gonna
watch something a little different today
I'm gonna watch a trailer yeah I'm still
watching a trailer but it's the honest
trailer for Star Wars Episode two attack
of the clones
so ours is kind of thing I love when
it's on when it's not on I'm kind of
like okay honest trailers man the screen
junkies there's some cool [ __ ]
youtubers man if you haven't seen their
honest trailers yet why not get a
[ __ ] life and get on YouTube and
watch it and I'm excited to see this as
stars for Star Wars man yeah the shit's
so funny and I haven't seen this one yet
it's their newest one I'm excited to
watch this let's do it do it take the
clones
from the man who created some of your
fondest childhood memories then took a
huge dump on him but uh sequel that
proved Phantom Menace wasn't an accident
this isn't how it's awfully Star Wars
Episode two attack of the clones
once again the Republic is in turmoil
watch as the chin stroking jeddah
between a completely disposable deployed
army and a completely disposable clone
army seriously there's no reason to get
emotionally involved in any of this crap
nope experienced an awkward forced love
story and as the computer it was made in
with so many visual effects the
filmmakers didn't have any time left
over for things like realistic
choreography realistic dialogue I'm
haunted by the kiss that you should
never hear so Brad realistic Hayden
Christensen acting I don't like send its
course rough and irritated
he made Darth Vader so stupid not like
here come on JJ there is no way you can
do any worse than this Natalie Portman
and her space hair return ah Padme
Amidala went to the galaxy's best sharp
shooting assassins try to kill her with
a poisonous worm pooping robot two Jedi
Warriors will come to her aid obi-wan
Kenobi a man forced to act opposite
lifeless CGI characters like Hayden
Christensen Walker
a rat tail dat soul who's been pre
police talking bad may for the last
decade I've thought about her every day
since we've parted I don't think she
liked me watching
I'd much rather dream about Padme you're
exactly the way beyond my dreams [ __ ]
hate this dude it makes me feel
uncomfortable
serve her right along with these
one-dimensional heroes in a movie so
unevenly paced you'll have to wait over
an hour before you even meet the main
villain instead strap yourself in for
even more the stuff that made phantomon
is so cold lifeless and boring like
people sitting and talking standing and
talking walking and talking one person
standing and talking while another is
sitting and talking but people stand and
you're talking then taking a seat for
budget
story hey don't act again huh in a bad
movie
yogurt my sit ha ha ha
Laurence Fishburne definitely not the
Edward [ __ ] darts are uber and
Django unbraid star knives
episode 11 attack of the clones so
correct me if I'm wrong here but the
clones never actually attack anyone in
this movie so what would you call this
movie attack of the clones [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] that is the truth of Star Wars and
if that is your first time watching an
honest trailer I'm sure you want to
watch more that [ __ ] is so funny and
true you know sometimes I watch it on
this trailer and I'm like I didn't
realize how much bad stuff was in this
movie until now but yeah [ __ ] manna
that was that was hilarious if you're
new to the channel subscribe thank you
it'd be cool if you subscribe so we can
interact Aaron gaze ero five-0
Aaron gray zero five zero three sorry
man I totally misread that I did not see
that are there but if you are gay good
for you man way to be confident in
yourself glad you're out there just
putting your penis in people's Bibles
that's awesome dude
you wanted to shout out so here it is
Aaron gay stay gray you gay
I like gays gays are cool more gay guys
and I'm eating girls and Audrey he said
I look smart with glasses and he also
requested a shout-out so Audrey I think
you're Indonesian stay Indonesian my
friend don't change your ethnicity try
to state because I know Indonesians
evolved until I beautiful human angels
but some of those angels have fallen and
then they made movies about them like
the Noah story really don't know where
I'm going with this
Julian exim Berger said he will rip my
spool out of my body spoil what the [ __ ]
are you referring to small does that a
thing means scull spine soul what is it
correct yourself fixin burger